let's say there are a couple of herbs
that people believe help help prevent
the flu so to test this what we do is we
wait for flu season and we randomly
assign people to three different groups
and over the the course of flu season we
have them either in one group taking
herb one and the second group taking
herb two and in the third group they
take a placebo and if you don't know
placebo is it's something that to the
patient or to the person participating
it feels like they're taking something
that you've told them might help them
but it does nothing it could be just a
sugar pill just so it feels like
medicine the reason why you go even go
through the effort of giving them
something is because often times or
something called the placebo effect
where people get better just because
they're being told that they're giving
that they're being given something that
will make them better so this could be
this could right here and just be a
sugar pill this right here could just be
a sugar pill and a very small amount of
sugar so it really can't affect their
their actual likelihood of getting the
flu so what let over here we have a
table and this is actually called a
contingency table contingency table
contingency table and it has on it in
each group the number that got sick the
number that didn't get sick and so we
also can from this calculate the total
number so in group in Group one we had a
total of 120 people and group two we had
a total of 30 plus 110 is 140 people and
in the placebo group the groups that the
group just got the sugar pill we had
total of 120 people and then we could
also tabulate the number of people the
total number of people that got sick so
that's 20 plus 30 is 50 plus 30 is 80 so
I mean this is the total column right
over here and then the total people that
didn't get sick over here is 100 plus
110 is 210 plus 90 is 300 300 and then
the total people here are 380 both this
column and this row should add up to 380
so with that out of the way let's think
about how we can use this information in
the contingency table and our knowledge
of the chi-squared distribution to come
up with some conclusion
so let's just make a null hypothesis our
null hypothesis is that the herbs do
nothing the null hypothesis is let's
just assume let me get some space here
so let's assume the null hypothesis that
the herbs herbs do nothing do nothing
and then we have our alternative
hypothesis our alternative hypothesis
that the herbs do something herbs do
something notice I'm not I don't even
care whether they actually improve I'm
just saying they do something they might
even increase your likelihood of getting
the flu we're not testing whether
they're actually good we're just saying
are they different than just doing
nothing so like we did do with all of
our hypothesis tests let's just assume
the null we're going to assume assume
the null and given that assumption
figure out the props
figure out if the likelihood of getting
data like this or more extreme is really
low and if it is really low then we will
reject the null hypothesis and in this
test like every hypothesis test we need
a significance level and let's say our
significance level we care about for
whatever reason is 10 percent or 0 zero
point one zero or 10 percent that's the
significance level that we care about
now to do this we have to figure out we
have to calculate a chi-square test
statistic for this contingency table and
to do that we do it very similar to what
we did with the restaurant situation we
figure out assuming the null hypothesis
the expected results you would have
gotten in each of these in each of these
cells you can view each of these entries
as a cell you know that's what we do
with it you called each of those entries
in excel also a cell d2 the entries in
the table what we do is we figure out
what the expected value would have been
would have been if the null hypothesis
if you do assume the null hypothesis
then we find this we the squared
distance from that expected value and we
we I usually call it normalize it by the
expected value take the sum of all of
those differences and if that's if that
if those difference is those squared
differences are really big the
probability of getting it would be
really small and maybe we'll reject the
null hypothesis so let's just figure out
how we can get the expected the expected
number so we're assuming the IRB's do
nothing so if the herbs do nothing then
we can just figure out then you know
this whole population they just had
nothing happened to them these herbs
were useless and so we can figure we can
use this population sample or I
shouldn't call it the population we
should use this sample right here to
figure out the expected number of people
who would get sick or not sick and so
over here over here we have 80 out of
three hundred eighty did not get sick
and I want to be careful I just said the
word population but we haven't sampled
the whole universe of all people taking
this herbs this is a sample so I don't
want to confuse you as using the
population and more of the
conversational sense than the
statistical sense anyway of our sample
and we're using all of the data because
we you know there's we're assuming
there's no difference so we might as
well just use the total data to figure
out the expected frequency of getting
sick and not getting sick so 80 divided
by 380 did not get sick and that's 21%
21% did not get sick so let me write
that over here so 21 and that's 21% of
the total and then if this would be 79%
if we just subtract 1 minus 21 we could
divide 300 by 380 we should get 79% as
well so you would expect one would
expect the 21% of each of your total
based on the total sample right over
here that you our best guess is a 21%
should be getting sick and 79% should
not be getting sick so let's look at it
for each of these groups if we assume
that 21% of these 120 people should have
gotten sick what would have been the
expected value right over here so let's
just multiply 21% let's just multiply
this 21% times 120 so let's just
multiply that times 120 that gets us to
25 point I'll just around a twenty five
point three people should have gotten
sick so the expected so let me write it
over here I'll do expected in in yellow
so the expected the expected right over
here if you assume the 21 percent of
each group should have gotten sick is
that you would have expected twenty five
point three people to get sick in Group
one and herb one group
and then the remainder will not get sick
so let's just let's just subtract let's
just or I could actually multiply 79%
times 120 either one of those will be
good but let me just take 120 minus
twenty five point three and then I get
ninety four point seven ninety four
point seven so you would have expected
94.7 to not get sick 94 so this is
expected again expected expected ninety
four point seven and not get sick and
I'll let's do that for each of these
groups so once again group two you would
have expected twenty one percent to get
sick twenty one percent of the total
people in that group so that's one
hundred and forty so that's twenty nine
point four and then the remainder see
one forty - twenty nine point four
should not have gotten sick so that gets
us this right here we have Twenty twenty
nine point four should have gotten sick
if the herbs did nothing and then over
here we would have 110 110 0.6 should
not have gotten sick and these are
pretty close so just looking at the
numbers it looks like this herb doesn't
do too much relative to the total or all
of the groups combined and then in the
placebo group let's see what happens
let's see what happens you have thirty
I'm sorry
we expect 21% to get sick twenty-one
percent of our group of 120 so it's
twenty five point two twenty five point
two so this right over here and actually
I should I should make this should be a
twenty five point since we're rounding
actually these will be the same number
over here so I said twenty one percent
but it's twenty-one point something
something something the group sizes are
the same so we should expect the same
proportion to get sick so I'll say
twenty five point three just to make it
consistent the reason why I got twenty
five point two just now is this because
I lost some of the trailing decimals
over here but since I had them over here
I'm going to use them over here as well
and then over here in this group you
would like you would expect 94.7 ninety
four point seven to get sick so if you
just actually relied on this data it
looks like herb two is that
to some degree even worse then it's even
worse than the oh no no I take that back
it's not worse because you would have
expected a small number and a lot of
people got sick here so this is the
placebo well anyway we don't want to
make judgments just staring at the
numbers let's figure out our chi-square
test statistic and to do that let's get
our statistic our chi-square statistic
I'll write it like this maybe for fun or
maybe I'll write it as a big X because
it's really it this this this random
variables distribution is approximately
a chi-squared distribution so I'll write
it like that and well we'll talk about
the degrees of freedom in a second
actually let me write it the Curley
extra so you see that some people write
it with the KY instead of the X so our
chi-square statistic over here we're
literally just going to find the the
squared distance between the observed
and expected and then divide it by the
expect it's going to be twenty minus
twenty five point three twenty minus
twenty five point three squared over
twenty five point three twenty five
point three plus 30 minus twenty nine
point four squared over twenty nine
point four I'm going to run out of space
plus 30 minus twenty five point three
squared over twenty five point three and
I'm gonna have to do these over here so
let me just continue it you can ignore
this h1 over here so plus plus 100 minus
ninety four point seven squared over
ninety four point seven plus I think you
see where this going 110 minus 110 0.6
squared over 110 point six and then
finally plus ninety over ninety four
point sorry
ninety minus ninety four point seven
scroll to the right a little bit squared
all of that over ninety four point seven
so let me just get the calculator out to
calculate this take a little bit of time
so we have to type it on the calculator
for these parentheses so we have twenty
minus
20-25 point 3 squared divided by 25
point 3 plus open parentheses 30 minus
20 9 point 4 squared divided by twenty
nine point four plus open parentheses 30
minus twenty five point three twenty
five point three squared divided by
twenty five point three halfway there
plus 100 open parentheses this is a
tedious part 100 minus ninety four point
seven squared divided by ninety four
point seven plus 110 - well this will I
liked you type it out we could do a lot
of these in our head but let me just do
it 110 minus 110 point six squared
divided by 110 point six and then last
one homestretch assuming we haven't made
any mistakes we have 90 minus ninety
four point seven squared divided by
ninety four point seven and let's see
what we get
we get two point five two eight so let's
just say it's two point five three so
r-ky our chi-square just statistic I
always have trouble saying that our
chi-square statistic assuming the null
hypothesis is correct is equal to two
point five two point five three now the
next thing we have to do is figure out
the degrees of freedom that we had in
calculating this chi-square statistic
and I'll give you the rule of thumb and
I'll give you a little bit of a sense of
why this is the rule of thumb for
contingency table like this and then the
future we'll talk a little bit more
deeply about degrees of freedom so when
you do the rule of thumb for contingency
table is you have the number of rows so
you have rows and then you have your
number of columns so here we have two
rows and we have three columns you don't
count the
littlez so you have three columns over
here and the degrees of freedom the
degrees of freedom and this is the rule
of thumb the degrees of freedom for your
contingency table is going to be the
number of rows minus one times the
number of columns minus one in our
situation we have two rows and three
columns so it's going to be two minus
one times three minus one so it's going
to be 2 minus 1 times 3 minus 1 which is
just 1 times 2 which is 2 we have two
degrees of freedom now the reason that
that should make a little bit of
intuitive sense we'll talk about this in
more depth in the future is that if you
if you assume that you know the totals
so let's just assume that you know the
total so if you know all of this
information over here if you know the
total information or if you knew the
parameters of the population as well but
if you know the total information and if
you know this information or if you know
if you know R minus 1 of the R minus 1
of the information in the rows the last
one can be figured out just by
subtracting from the total so for
example in this situation if you know
this you can easily figure out this this
is not new information it's just a total
minus 20 same thing if you know this one
right over here this one over here is
not new information and similarly if you
know these two this guy over here isn't
new information you can just you can
always just calculate him based on the
total and everything else so that's the
sense of why our degrees of freedom are
the columns minus 1 times the rows minus
1 but anyway so our chi-square statistic
has two degrees of freedom so what we
have to do is remember our alpha value
let me get it up here we have it right
over here our significance level that we
care about our alpha value is 10% let me
rewrite it over here so our alpha is 10%
so what we're going to do is figure out
what is the critical Chi what is our
critical chi-square statistic that gives
us an alpha of 10% if this is more
extreme than that if the probability of
getting this is even less than that
critical statistic it'll be less than
10% and we'll reject the null hypothesis
if it's not more extreme then we won't
reject
null hypothesis so what we need to do is
to figure out with a chi-squared
distribution and two degrees of freedom
what is our critical chi-square
statistic so let's just go back so we
have two degrees of freedom we have two
degrees of freedom here and we have a
critical we care about a significance
level of 10 percent 10 percent so our
critical our critical chi-square value
is four point six zero so another way to
visualize this if we look at the
chi-square distribution with two degrees
of freedom that's this blue one over
here this blue one over here at a value
of trying to pick up nice blue to use at
a value of a critical value of four
point six zero so four point six zero
this is five so four point six zero will
be right around here at a critical value
of four point six zero so this is four
point six zero you have it the
probability of getting something that
ecstatic stream so that extreme or more
extreme is ten percent this is our this
is what we care about
now if the chi-square statistic that we
calculated falls into this rejection
region then we're going to reject the
null hypothesis but our chi-squared
statistic statistic is only two point
five three it is only two point five
three so it's sitting it's sitting
someplace right over here is actually
ours so it's actually very it's not that
crazy to get it if you assume the null
hypothesis so based on our data that we
have right now we cannot reject the null
hypothesis so we cannot we don't know
for a fact that the IRB's do nothing but
we can't say that they do something
based on this so we're not going to
reject it we won't say 100% that is true
but we can't say that we're rejecting it
so at least from this point of view we
it doesn't look like the IRB's did
anything that would make us believe that
they that they're any different then
then each other and one of the herbs is
obviously a placebo so any different
than a placebo or each other